[Music]
[Applause]
ken burns is a great documentary
filmmaker i don't know how i'm going to
make this segway but i'm going to put
you in a really good idea
you did but he did the vietnam war he
did uh the history of baseball he did
the civil war and he has a new
documentary that uh premieres it's
september 19th through the 22nd on pbs
and it's a four-part film by ken burns
his oldest daughter sarah and her
husband david uh mcmahon
and uh ken burns kind enough to join us
on the program
when did muhammad ali become a hero
i think he was a hero
almost from the beginning um
that
that kind of
pan world here heroism happens at the
towards the end as as we let go of the
memories of some of the divisive aspects
but he's at the beginning he's saying
i'm pretty as a girl i'm black i'm
beautiful he is providing many people in
this country
with phrases and and purchase for
ideas that they didn't have we made a
film on jackie robinson he redefined
black manhood black masculinity muhammad
ali came along and redefined it in a
different way athletes weren't supposed
to speak that way they weren't supposed
to to brag and certainly black athletes
weren't supposed to do that and he did
it anyway and and just brought him into
so many people's hearts if he turned off
some other people and then he joins a
separatist religious sect which turns
off another group of people and then
strike three he joins he refuses to uh
induction into the united states army
and so we think of him as divisive he's
also quite uh provocative uh about how
he treats his opponents joe frazier for
example
todd boyd the scholar says in our film
you know he he uses the language that a
white racist would use about a black man
to describe his opponent to black men
and um it's inexcusable and yet emerging
out of it is a person always with a sort
of
a joie de vivre a kind of great sense of
humor um a sense of natural promoting in
a very american sense and and a kind of
beauty i mean he's the greatest athlete
of the 20th century maybe of all time
he's won the championship uh three times
even though he lost three and a half
years at the height of his power because
of his religious beliefs this is a black
man saying i won't fight in the vietnam
war for religious reasons an american
can only hear black man doesn't want to
go he's giving us the middle finger this
is a political gesture so even though
the prosecutors are suggesting a more
lenient sentence the draw the judge
sends him to the maximum five years and
when he's exonerated he begins to come
back he begins a climb that begins with
some wins but most significantly in the
fight of the century in 71 against joe
frazier a loss which he takes very well
he's behind on points he goes out in the
last round he's knocked down he gets
back up again he's very soft-spoken and
speaks about the larger sense of being a
role model even in loss
and from then on it's just robert
libside in our film says joe frazier won
the fight but but muhammad ali won
america and i think from that moment on
it just goes exponentially so that when
he dies not too long ago as you know
2016 he dies the most
beloved person on the planet which has
got to tell you something
i couldn't help but notice this ken
when i'm when i'm watching this that
it's almost like he was
he was able to listen to what people say
about you after you die because once
muhammad ali like he was awake for his
funeral because he was people were
they were comfortable talking about ali
as if he was past
because he couldn't speak
and it just dawned on me that
what that must have been like for ali to
listen i mean he probably loved it
because you know still talking yeah they
were saying all these nice things i was
also curious about his ring bravado
and it brought about images of maybe
wrestling like wrestlers were over the
top and gregarious and i wondered
because we didn't have that boxers
weren't like that athletes weren't like
that like where did that come from well
you know david remnick the the writer
and biographer early biographer of of
cassius clay muhammad ali
also talked about one of the great
inspirational moments he's in las vegas
for a fight but he goes and he sees
gorgeous george who was the villain in
wrestling who permed up his hair and was
preening and whatever and wearing this
outlandish stuff and and and kind of on
androgynous at times and and he
understood that it didn't matter people
paid to see him and paid to hate him and
he that's what he said boo his throw
peanuts but whatever you do pay to get
in and i think he understood a
fundamental
aspect of american hype of pt barnum ism
is is it it didn't really matter and
that he could still be provocative may i
just admit as i should have at the at
the start this is a film directed by my
daughter sarah burns and and david
mcmahon her husband we've been
collaborating together in a lot of
things as well as me but it's also to
acknowledge there are lots of
documentaries on muhammad ali and there
are several really good documentaries on
muhammad ali really really good and we
don't mean to suggest that they are not
we wanted to do something comprehensive
from boyhood birth and boyhood and
segregated jim crow louisville to death
by parkinson's in 2016 and not just
follow the fights and not just pay lip
service to the nation of isan but
understand him as being a human being on
a very legitimate and genuine spiritual
quest and also the personal stuff and
the family and the biography and the
wives and the children and so this is
this is as i think as comprehensive as
you can get in terms of the arc of the
life of one of the most extraordinary
americans who's ever lived it's a
four-part film by uh ken and his
daughter and her husband and a premier
september 19th through the 22nd on on
pbs how do you find the sweet spot
for a documentary
you know it you would you would presume
that this is an additive process you
know like you're building a house it's
subtractive dan you know
we collect
you know this is eight hours long we've
got four or 500 hours of material right
and then you're distilling it to use a
louisville kentucky term you're
distilling it down to a kind of essence
and so our cutting room floor is not
filled with bad stuff it's filled with
really really good stuff that you'd look
at and go burns you've lost your mind
why isn't that in there and you go well
it was there for six months but it
seemed to destabilize that so our
process is
always being open you know it's not a
set research period followed by a
writing period that produces a script
that informs the shooting and editing
boom done we never stopped researching
and we found stuff no one has ever put
forward before because we spent with pbs
we spent seven years no no suit is
saying i need this by the summer how
often do people stop you on the street
and say i got a great idea for a
documentary every day what's the
strangest
suggestion
well what one person wanted to be they
said here i'm giving you they mailed
this in i'm giving you the four volumes
of my grandfather's memoir of his civil
war years although i'd done the civil
war turns out he never left maine
but
but they you know self-publish this
memoir okay um so i finally after about
10 years i did it up the number one
thing is railroads the number two thing
is labor the next thing is education and
then they're just you know you got to do
this and they're all right and i'm
working on seven films right now because
i am 68 years old and i know if i were
given a thousand years to live which i
will not i would not run out of topics
in american history and so i want to do
i've got four different producing teams
sarah and dave are one of them and we're
just working on as many as we can in
different stages of undress and
because i'm greedy for that experience
of of finding the sweet spot i mean i
want to put my head on the pillow at the
end of the day and say god i made at
least one of them better give me the
sports documentary that hasn't been done
but should be
that's a really good question um
i tried in baseball i did an update the
10th inning i promised people that if
the cubs won the world series
george will said well they're having a
bad century and it turned out that's all
it was was a bad century in a decade so
i've got to do that at some point
there's a lot of nice new stuff about it
but i got to just find the bandwidth to
do that you know i i love baseball it's
the greatest sport ever invented i love
football a lot and i'd like to see
something done i guess in football that
isn't just
you know
the dramas of the reality tv nature of
the
of the behind the scenes i i don't know
what that is right now uh but nothing
compares to baseball and it's funny i'm
not a boxing fan i made two boxing films
they total you know uh 12 hours of time
on jack johnson four and and on this one
eight
um but it's only because um
these two men were so transcendent i
mean i a lot of the sports writers uh
who i've done lots of interviews with
and we've got three of the very best
writer lib site dave kindred and and um
and jerry eisenberg in the film who were
cubs growing up with muhammad ali and
love him and care about him and
remember each bad punch but um
you know i would ask each one and no
one's answered i said who's the
heavyweight champion right now
it doesn't matter after muhammad ali you
got a little dribble of mike tyson and
then you know what it does not matter
until somebody else like him comes along
and hate to give away the plot
no one like muhammad ali is ever coming
along again
do you need coffee or a nap
i don't drink coffee because there's no
problem getting me out of bed what i
need is uh you know the conch on the
head at the end of the day
it just just to shut the thing up thank
you ken well done as always
thank you great to be with you that's
ken burns muhammad ali for part film
with
ken his oldest daughter and her husband
premieres
sunday september 19th through the 22nd
on pbs